ihr kennt Unternehmen den er Obstschale
haben ihr kennt Unternehmen die den
kickerkasten haben aber ich wette mit
euch nicht mal Google oder Facebook hat
eine eigene firmensauna drum bauen wir
jetzt eine in den Garten und weil so ein
Saunaofen ganz schön auf die
Stromrechnung drückt kommt oben drauf
noch ein Solarpanel um den
Stromverbrauch auszugleichen genau wie
schon bei der Gartenhütte die wir vor
ein paar Wochen gebaut haben ist das
Panel von Anker unserem heutigen Sponsor
aber mehr dazu später dann der Platz
also nicht kommen aber hier ebenso als
Verlängerung zu dieser Hecke schon
wieder Bodenanker und nivellieren und
mega unterkonstrukt runterbauen oder wie
ja wo im Garten würde es das Bauen wo du
davon ausgeht dass der Boden schon im
Wasser ist auf der Terrasse
ja okay also hier sollst du sein mit
Blickrichtung darüber Blickrichtung
Garten macht schon Sinn aus müssen
Sichtschutz süße dann so halbwegs live
begleitet in der Sauna und dann kommst
du raus und dann ist die Hecke hier
kannst du schon Cosi wieder reingehen
das finde ich ganz geil nachdem kommt
müssen wir mal schauen wie die Sonne
aussehen soll die Sonne
das hat mir gerade im Segment gesehen
Inspiration einfach mal auf Google es
gibt ja voll fancy Sachen zuschauen
quadratisch praktisch gut fertig vom
Designer ganz geil finde ist sowas das
hatte ich auch noch für halbwegs machbar
einfach rund angelegt voll finde ich
auch schön wenn ich nicht bauen müsste
aber sind daran so schwer ja es stellt
sich meistens
herausfinden sind die terrassend nehmen
niemals sich kriegen willst
[Musik]
ja auch oder Kiefer
ein bisschen dunkler und im Hintergrund
ist einfach Fichte und die ist einfach
blass nee also du hast ja schon schön
mit der Konstruktion so richtig losgehen
wir wollen ja am Tag quasi ein
Solarzelle und dann müssen wir uns
erstmal überlegen wie wir das Befestigen
so machen wir erstmal davon aus was ist
das denn
was um das irgendwie fest zu machen
braucht man das alles nee kannst ja
aussuchen also du kannst es entweder
irgendwie am Balkon festmachen oder mit
dem Garten aufstellen und je nachdem wo
du das machen willst kannst du dir das
Aussuchen
schon fett 35,3 vielleicht so ich habe
gerade ein bisschen
jetzt aber nichts wie rein ins
CAD-Programm und dran ans konstruieren
der Sauna
[Musik]
also ich finde das sieht ein bisschen zu
seiner Klo aus
deswegen und ich bin damit noch nicht
fertig wollte ich euch fragen bevor ich
jetzt weiter mache habe ich mir so eine
Form überlegt
das ist gar nicht so wild
glaube ich auch cool also das heißt
dann wo das jetzt geklärt ist das geht
um die Größe und auch um die Türen das
ist einmal die hier die ist leider teuer
aber sieht cool aus dann haben wir als
Option noch die hier jetzt prinzipiell
Frage diese Bronze Farbe ja oder nein
ich glaube wenn man das ganze so
dunkelgrau streicht und dann diese Türe
macht dann könnte das moderner Aussehen
gut dann kommen wir zur Größe so klein
wie es geht wäre es hier 180 breit ja
lass uns am besten anschauen also 30
tief könnte man sagen wenn ich ganz nice
weil dann steht das halt nicht den Weg
minimal mehr wie der Busch eigentlich
und jetzt ist die Länge interessant die
ist wichtig für die Optik weil so ein
Hochhaus oder hässlich auseinander wenn
halt irgendwas breiter ist es ein
bisschen schöner als darum geht's mir
eigentlich und das werden jetzt 180
rein und jetzt hier schon direkt der der
Ofen ne dann hockst du hier dann passt
man vielleicht hier okay zwei Leute rein
hier nochmal zwei der eine der Hardcore
ist direkt am Ofen sitzt hätte
vielleicht gesagt
kann man eigentlich theoretisch auch
hier auf 140 gehen so ja für mich passt
das hassen das ist größer geworden ist
also 140 x 2 m und nach ungelogen fünf
Stunden konzentrieren am Rechner
ist das der fertige Plan für die Sauna
und ohne die Verkleidung sieht man dann
auch das Innenleben richtig gut und man
sieht auch das ist eine Etagen Sauna ist
die ich so im Internet überhaupt nicht
gefunden habe weil normal liegen immer
auf Treppen sind aber so viel Platz
haben wir in unserer kleinen Sauna gar
nicht und mit dem Plan geht's für Mann
und Pascal am nächsten Morgen ab in den
Baumarkt
[Musik]
so hier Grundsteinlegung ja der Plan ist
jetzt ein bisschen wild wir werden jetzt
als erstes mal das Zeug haben
[Musik]
ja perfekt das brauchen
und damit ist es jetzt perfekt im Wasser
soll natürlich nicht so bleiben ja wir
haben uns jetzt erstmal nur ein bisschen
mit Wasser gebracht womit ich jetzt
quasi hier mit dem Stück Schnur und am
schweren Stück Eisen das ja einmal
lotmäßig nach unten verlängern kann um
es dann zu markieren
[Musik]
15 cm zu lang ja also pascal hat gesagt
Abriss damit können wir uns ja aus und
damit hat verdammt recht ich glaube Manu
will einfach nicht dass wir diese Sauna
bauen Alter
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wir müssen ja echt alle absägen noch mal
ne wir müssen das komplette normale
nicht
[Musik]
also ich finde es richtig geil sieht von
unten episch aus passt auch also ein
bisschen genauer als das letzte Mal
geworden tatsächlich auch aber es regnet
auch tatsächlich in Strömen deshalb
bauen wir jetzt den Rest erstmal hier
drin
aufgeschnitten hat Anfang tun wir mit
der Innenkonstruktion und das sind diese
innen Bögen die wurden hier wie war das
Erlebnis
diese Maschine
[Musik]
wollten wir sie nicht dass sie hier so
haben wir noch gesagt
und dann kannst du da die Blätter nicht
anschauen gedacht dass man nur auf einer
Seite die die Waffe genau macht aber
dann hält er auch nichts ne ich habe
eine Idee
[Musik]
das jetzt schon
fast
das war nicht meine leben
[Musik]
die erste Seite quasi dass die erste
Seite die müssen jetzt erstmal
raustragen und Manu meinte es geht auf
jeden Fall durch die Tür und wir sollen
uns keine Sorgen machen
ja aber lass mal diagonal probieren ja
sage ich doch
[Gelächter]
hat durchgepasst viel Spaß
[Musik]
also leider ist die Tür jetzt ein
bisschen größer als die Sauna deswegen
muss ich jetzt ein bisschen was zu Segen
aber das wird schon richtig geil also
jeder der beruflich irgendwas mit Türen
zu tun hat kriegt aber ein Herzinfarkt
aber es wird es wird geil
was ist das für ein Geräusch gewesen
[Musik]
so komm dann später wieder rein ja uns
ist dann jetzt eingefallen dass wir die
Tür um 90 Grad verdreht eingeplant haben
ja und deswegen haben wir die Dinger
herausgesägt aber so eine 90 Grad
verdrehte Tür ist eigentlich eher
unpraktisch also haben wir sie wieder
reingeklebt gut wir bauen das mal
zusammen jetzt kein Fehler machen das
wäre wirklich smart eigentlich so also
er kommt hier hin
oh mann
einfach eigentlich noch meine zwinge
holen und das Teil auch fest zwingen so
wie hier eigentlich smart
[Musik]
so richtig schön rausgekommen ist hatte
ich die Idee jetzt erst aufzubauen
hierfür brauchen wir jetzt gerade das
balkonkraftwerk von dem das Video auch
unterstützt wird und hängen vor erstmal
die Panels hier an den Balkon direkt
neben die Sauna und später kommt auch
noch eins auf
die Panels können aber auch überall
montiert werden also auch einfach im
Garten oder später auf dem saunada das
System ist leicht zu installieren und
man braucht keine Elektriker die Penis
werden einfach in den mikrokonverter
gesteckt und am Ende kommt dieser
Stecker in den normale Steckdose und der
Strom des balkonkraftwerks wird ins Haus
Netz eingespeist was ihr hier per App in
Echtzeit überwachen könnt und mit den
bis zu 600 Watt die das balkonkraftwerk
produziert braucht ihr auch keine
Genehmigung sondern es reicht eine
schnelle Anmeldung die einfach kostenlos
von zu Hause machen können wie das genau
geht habe ich mal verlinkt für 30 Jahre
Nutzung sind die Panels designt und dank
der Wasserfestigkeit des
stromschlagschutzes und der stabilen
Befestigung ist die Nutzung auch absolut
sicher und Anker gibt's beim Sony x
rs40p ganze 15 Jahre Garantie dieses
high-dentity Panel mit 15 Bus Bars und
einem Wirkungsgrad von 22,7 %. ist 10 %
effektiver als herkömmliche Penis mit
dem komplett schwarzen Look sehen ja
auch noch viel besser aus also klickt
auf den Link in der Videobeschreibung
und erhaltet mit meinem Code WS an
katomary 12 % Rabatt noch ein kleiner
Adapter gebaut damit ich das Solarpanel
auch direkt an Gleichstrom stecken kann
und damit dreht sich jetzt dieser
Propeller und macht gut Wind aber
der rasiert hat einfach auf dem Platz
aber ich stecke das wieder in den
Converter weil wir wollen sie eigentlich
im Haushalt haben also Pascal und nix
schnappen und sitzt die Latten und
werden schon mal die Sitzbänke
zusammenschrauben
[Musik]
die obere Liege ist fertig jetzt kommt
die untere dran
[Musik]
also als erstes montieren wir jetzt den
Boden von dem ganzen außenkonstrukt hier
und dafür müssen wir das ganze Teil
irgendwie einmal umkippen und ich hoffe
sonst fällt nicht den Hang runter
und lass es irgendwie überstehen da sind
die dann jetzt alle zu lang das schaut
richtig bescheuert aus der Nähe
noch mal sagen wir mal irgendwer hat
sich vielleicht wieder versägt
Planänderung wir machen erst vorne und
hinten bevor wir den Boden machen
[Musik]
so eine Seite fertig umdrehen nächste
Seite
ja nachdem ich jetzt hier kein einziges
Brett dran gemacht habe
gedreht
[Musik]
also hä was was ist das denn nicht
gehalten hat
[Musik]
das ist so clean mit dieser Gottlosen
Säge einfach das viel besser als guten
Dinge
[Musik]
passt beim Zusammenschrauben des Bodens
haben wir wieder dasselbe Problem wie
bei unserem Gartenhaus dass wir vor ein
paar Wochen zusammengebaut haben viel zu
viele Bretter können wir einfach gar
nicht hernehmen weil die Verarbeitung
eher so Mittel ist und Astlöcher wie
beim Gartenhaus da waren es einige gehen
natürlich gar nicht klar weil die Sauna
sonst viel zu undicht ist um warm zu
werden so jetzt wird spannend weil wir
gehen jetzt um die Kurve und ähm ja die
Dinger lustig
[Musik]
[Applaus]
nachdem die Ecke jetzt fertig und echt
besser aussehen als befürchte wie immer
also ich habe es eigentlich schon genau
mir so vorgestellt aber ja das ist geil
ähm geht jetzt wieder über geraden und
nach ordentlich Schrauberei fehlt nur
noch das letzte kleine Stück und damit
das rein passt habe ich erstmal der
Länge nach halbiert und dann an der
Oberfräse eine neue Feder Gefäß die dann
in die Not des anderen Bretts gesteckt
werden kann
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die Sauna steht jetzt sie ist
wunderschön genauso wie ich mir
vorgestellt habe allerdings fehlt
natürlich noch ein bisschen Farbe aber
bevor ich die jetzt final und
unwiderruflich auf die Sauna
draufstreicht probiere ich erstmal aus
und da verrühre ich erstmal um weil das
ist ja komplett undurchmischt
ordentlich durchgerührt probiere ich
jetzt als allererstes mal das Grau mit
dem quasi die Sauna eingestrichen wird
[Musik]
und dann noch die andere Glasur für
diesen Außenring bisschen orange Lichter
so sieht das dann aus einmal hier das
Orange haben wir das Grau finde ich sehr
sehr nice hier habe ich noch mal die
Beize probiert aber das gefällt mir
eigentlich überhaupt nicht wir haben
jetzt gerade die Tür reingesetzt um zu
sehen wie rum wir die Tür genau machen
wollen und ja wir müssen jetzt noch die
rausnehmen
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
Alter
ja wir müssen jetzt machen das war ein
bisschen blöd geplant
sehr gut
warte mal kurz anders
[Musik]
die Tür Alter ist halt jetzt komplett
verspannt
[Musik]
die Tür jetzt auch nicht auf oder so und
nachdem wir die Tür zu graziös und
definitiv 100% fachmännisch eingefügt
haben können auch schon die Bretter um
den Türrahmen herum versenkt werden so
dass die Tür am Schluss ordentlich in
die Außenwand der Sauna eingebettet ist
und der finde ich macht das nochmal
zehnmal cool also das sieht richtig geil
aus ich muss jetzt hier aufs Dach drauf
hüpfen und ja die Plane da
festnagelnetzt habe und es ist super
vertrauenserweckend ich habe überhaupt
voll Bock auf Leitern einfach
wir haben dafür so Nägel wie so ein
richtig fetten Kopf haben
ja mit denen wir das einmal das Dach
schön festgemacht
[Musik]
ich will jetzt dieses dachzeug haben wir
mal schön gerade abschneiden allerdings
ja ihr seht das Problem das ist jetzt
relativ unwegsames Gelände hier ist der
Hang des Todes ja mal schauen wie ich
das hinkriegt
so Nummer eins ja wieder nicht darüber
kommen soll das natürlich nicht das
Rätsel
das geht mir jetzt erstmal genial
[Musik]
gerade aber davon muss ich die Tatsache
dass ich das Dach noch mal hochklappen
kann die Sonne jetzt zu streichen das
macht das Holz
habe ich jetzt gar nicht benutzt weil
die war so deckend
[Musik]
hier sieht man so mal richtig gut wie
das jetzt aussehen wird
gefällt mir voll gut
[Musik]
es ist jetzt 11 Uhr nachts es regnet und
ich habe gerade mit diesem Teil die
Sauna fertig gestrichen
[Musik]
ja es ist wieder hell ich ziehe jetzt
mal die kreppbänder ab weil
Farbe ist schön getrocknet wie auch
immer es war nass
[Musik]
so gestern noch drunter gestrichen jetzt
fest
der Regen in die Augen ist richtig gut
und der ganze bitum auch richtig gut im
Gesicht
das sieht geil aus
[Applaus]
[Musik]
jetzt geht es zu den Steinen die in den
saunhof müssen
und die Fülle ich da jetzt mal rein
einfach reinwerfen
ach so ja klar meine ich ja
richtig eine kleine Sauna das Ziel war
aber das hier vier Leute reinpassen und
das demonstriere jetzt mal hier
kann man auch richtig viel Platz aber
das ist gar kein Problem für eine Person
dann kann man natürlich hier entweder
auch liegen oder zu zweit eine sitzt
hier
andere sitzt hier ja auch kein Problem
und natürlich nach oben hier auf der
Liege da hatte ich ein bisschen Angst
davor ursprünglich zu gehen einfach weil
ich nicht wusste wie stabil das Teil
wird aber das ist echt zu mir geworden
und deswegen ist es überhaupt kein
Problem hier oben zu liegen ja ist geil
die Tür hier ja die ist auch richtig
nice geworden
ist aber richtig schön getönt hier ich
mache jetzt mal den Ofen an wir lassen
ein bisschen vorheizen und dann gibt's
auch
[Musik]
sehr nice ja wir müssen auf jeden Fall
nach oben und wir brauchen auf jeden
Fall auch ein bisschen Aufguss direkt
sehr gut
[Musik]
die Kamera sieht schon gar nichts mehr
cool
[Musik]
ja also die Sauna
wurde ordentlich eingeweicht das ist
echt schön entspannt dann sage ich mal
vielen Dank an Anker fürs unterstützen
von dem Video die Links zum
balkonkraftwerk findet in der
Videobeschreibung ich hoffe es hat euch
gefallen und ich bin damit raus macht's